I was very good friends with Nino Scalia,
as I called him, not despite the fact that
we had very strong disagreements on issues
that were of fundamental importance to both
of us, but because of that fact, because of
those disagreements we were invited to debate
each other in various forums all over the
world.
And as is true for any two thinking people
there are some deeply important issues where
we strongly disagree, but also some issues
that are deeply important to both of us where
we strongly agree.
And both our mutual respect and liking arose
from the exchange of ideas in a respectful
manner, the open listening and grappling with
each other's ideas and doing it for an audience.
As a teacher and an advocate, I am so grateful
for Justice Scalia's generosity in speaking
before all kinds of audiences.
The mutual respect, I think, is evidenced
in the fact that we were doing those kinds
of events.
I would have liked him just for the fact that
he was engaging in that process of exchanging
ideas and he would often do it in audiences
that you could expect to be hostile to him,
right, not just preaching to the choir.
I think the most dramatic example was he agreed
to do one of these exchanges with me at an
ACLU National Membership Conference.
It's really sad that people seem to think
that if you disagree with somebody on some
issues you can't be mutually respectful, you
can't enjoy each other's company, you can't
learn from each other and grow in yourself.
Because I have found that having friendships
and collegial relationships with people with
whom I strongly disagree has been not only
advantageous to advancing causes and concerns
that are deeply important to me, but also
have just been so enjoyable on a personal
and human level and have really enriched my
life.
So, for example, I care very deeply about
education.
I think I'm a much more effective educator
when I teach students or speak before students
in the context of an exchange with somebody
else who has different ideas.
I think that deepens the student's understanding
of the multiple perspectives that are plausible
on particular issues and enriches their own
analysis and their own understanding.
Working with the ACLU, which has always been
a staunchly non-partisan organization by definition,
through our own corporate charter never oppose
or endorse any candidate, official, party
or organization, rather we will criticize
or praise every individual or every group
on an issue by issue basis.
And once you do that you have to acknowledge
that there is nobody with whom you do not
strongly agree on at least some important
issues, no matter how strongly you may disagree
on other important issues.
And in terms of advancing your causes, if
you can work together collaboratively with
somebody who you agree with on a particular
issue you should do that regardless of whether
you disagree with them on another issue.
It's going to make it easier and more likely
that you are going to succeed in your jointly
shared cause -- but also on a human level
it's just fun and interesting to get to know
and spend time with and learn from people
who have different ideas.